[موسيقى] أجنبية
تمامًا وفي كل مرة في
أهم لحظات مسيرتي
وضربت المثال بهذه المباراة في دبي
ضد كورنيكوف والملاعب المركزية عندما
كانت في أفضل حالاتها على المستوى
وفجأة أدركت أنني سأذهب
الفوز كان بإمكاني رؤية الاستاد ممتلئًا
وجميع الصحفيين قادمين لأنه
كانت نهاية المباراة
للمقابلة وأدركت ذلك
وفجأة كان الرقم القياسي ينتظر ربما
300 كيلو بدلاً من
نعم بدلاً من 100 جرام لذا في تلك
اللحظة كنت  لم يكن لدي أي فكرة عما كان يحدث بداخلي
ولكني تجمدت تمامًا للوصول إلى
جذور الأمر الذي
يأتي من الصدمة التي تعرضت لها
مع هذا الاعتداء الجنسي في
سن مبكرة جدًا وأعتقد أنني قمت بالارتباط به في
ذلك الوقت في المرة الأولى  هل حدث
لي اعتداء جنسي كان عمري 12 عامًا ولم يكن هناك
إنترنت ولا شيء لم يكن لدي أي فكرة عما
كان يحدث على الإطلاق وتجمدت في مكاني
لأن هذا ما
حدث عندما كانت هناك صدمة في ذلك
الوقت غادرت لأصدقائي عندما كان عمري 12 عامًا
بمفردي  من أجل أن أصبح
لاعب تنس محترفًا وبطلًا، وهذا ما يفعله
العقل
دون وعي بالطبع، فأنا
مرتبط تمامًا بالأداء على مستوى عالٍ أو
في تحقيق أشياء كبيرة لإساءة استخدامه
والذي كان من خطر الموت إلى حد
كبير لأنه كان  الشيء الأكثر إيلامًا
الذي حدث لي على الإطلاق،
ولذا في كل مرة كنت قريبًا جدًا من
تحقيق شيء أكبر
وأكبر، تجمدت في
سبب حديثي عن ذلك الآن وأنا أبلغ من
العمر 46 عامًا وقد حدث هذا منذ حوالي 35
عامًا، وهو أمر بالغ الأهمية  بكل بساطة، أعتقد أنني على ثقة من
أنني تغلبت على هذه الصدمة
بشكل كامل منذ عام ونصف فقط، فقط
إذا أعطينا صورة ربما كنت
أتغلب عليها عندما كنت في السبعين من عمري تقريبًا، ولكن لا
يزال هناك ثلاثة وثلاثين بالمائة هي
أعمق مستوى وأكثرها  معقدة
اه وقد قابلت هذا المعالج،
آسف هذا الشخص المحترف الذي هو
جيد للغاية ولديه
طريقة مختلفة على الرغم من أنني جربت كل
طريقة في العالم قبل ذلك على ما أعتقد وقد
قمت بعمل جيد حتى الآن ولكن
طريقته كانت بالتأكيد  سحري وفي
ذلك الوقت كان لدي هذا الإدراك الكبير
حيث علمت أن هذا هو هدفي
وقلت له استمع، هذه هي الطريقة
التي نحتاج إلى مشاركتها للمساعدة في
منع سوء المعاملة ولمساعدة
الأشخاص
أو سوء المعاملة على الشفاء لأن معظمهم  في بعض الأحيان
يكون الشفاء سطحيًا أو لا
يحدث على المستوى العميق تمامًا
لذلك قررت إنشاء شركة
مع هذا المحترف لمشاركة هذه
الطريقة وللمساعدة في منع إساءة الاستخدام في
المؤسسات الرياضية على وجه التحديد
وأيضًا للمساعدة في التغلب على الأشخاص الذين تعرضوا
للإيذاء للحصول على  لقد خرجت منها لذلك فتحت هذه
الشركة وتسمى unus Mundos for
all oneworld for all وهي شركة
للمساعدة على المستوى الجماعي،
لذا إذا كنت أرغب في المساعدة على
المستوى الجماعي، فأنا بحاجة أيضًا إلى مشاركة قصتي على
المستوى الجماعي  لأنني أؤمن
بالقيادة بالقدوة، لا أعتقد أن
تقديم النصيحة سيساعد كثيرًا، أعتقد أن
الإجراءات هي التي تساعد بالفعل، ليس من
السهل الحديث علنًا عن شيء مثل
هذا،
لذا فإن هذا إجراء أكثر
أهمية من النصيحة.  لا أؤمن
بإخبار الناس بما يجب عليهم فعله، فأنا أؤمن
بإظهار وإلهام
الوقاية، وهو برنامج وقائي مهم للغاية،
ما هي الوقاية؟ هناك
طريقة أخرى، هناك العديد من الطرق للوقاية
ولكن أفضل طريقة للوقاية خاصة
للأطفال هي تطوير مستوى أعلى
مستوى تقدير الذات واحترام الذات والثقة بالنفس
والتمكين
وبالطبع التحرر من عدم المحرمات،
أعني أنك تعرف أن الكثير من الناس لا يريدون
التحدث عن هذه الأشياء أمام
الأطفال كما لو كان هناك أطفال هنا
لا تتحدث عن ذلك، أخبرهم جيدًا، أنت
تعرف ماذا حدث عندما كان عمري 12 عامًا وقبل ذلك كنت
أتمنى لو كان هناك أشخاص يتحدثون معي عن
هذه الأشياء أمامي حتى
أعرف حقًا ما هي، كنت
سأفهم ما هي، لذلك ربما  كنت سأعرف
ما حدث لي وكان من الممكن أن
أتفاعل أو أتصرف، كما تعلم على سبيل
المثال، نعلم أننا
نشأنا في التعليم في كثير من
الأحيان بطريقة نخبرك بها أنك
تعرف ما لا يجيب عليه هذا الشخص البالغ مثل
هذا أنت  عليك أن تحترم الشخص صاحب السلطة الأكبر
منك
سنًا وما الذي يعنيه ذلك، لذلك عندما
يأتي شخص ذو سلطة
ويفعل بك شيئًا لا
تريد أن تفعله، عليك أن تكون مهذبًا ولا تقل
شيئًا بعد  تثقيفه بالطبع ليكون
مهذبًا ولكن هناك العديد من الطرق
لمنع التمكين وبالنسبة لي تأتي الوقاية
من التمكين من فتح
العقل من ترك المحرمات من المحرمات
حقًا والتعمق هناك وتحرير
معظم هذه
القيود التي تعرفها  التي لدينا في الواقع